this next story has a lot of twists and
turns so I hope asked that you stay with
me on it Facebook announced on yesterday
that they have pulled down approximately
32 campaigns that they consider to be
inauthentic now before I go any further
let's first talk about this word
inauthentic because Facebook and their
press release they never defined in
inauthentic nor did they define their
their methodology of determining what
was inauthentic or not now to be sure we
do have to be concerned with
Russian meddling or any other meddling
that occurs from a from a foreign nation
in our campaign right in our 2018
election cycle Russians got involved in
the 2016 election cycle at this point
anyone who doesn't admit that is being
absurd and ridiculous
but if we just throw a blanket statement
out there and say Facebook and they have
the arbitrary right they have the right
to just determine arbitrarily what is
inauthentic or not without disclosing to
the public their process in their
methodology that gives Facebook the
ability to just blanket pull down
anything that they want now only and in
our normal day you will have
conservatives making that argument that
I just made because it's the truth but
you're not going to see people like ben
shapiro sam harris and all of the free
speech absolutist on the right talking
about this in context of facebook today
because facebook pulled down a majority
of left-leaning
campaigns let's pull up a couple on the
screen at this point this is the first
one from resistors history has shown
that fascism must be stopped before it
becomes too late there was a trump
nightmare month in event scheduled for
the november 4th they pull down this
they put down the next one also from the
resistors talking about Columbus Day
saying that millions of indigenous
people died during the conquest of
America history is history but if we
want integrity and equality we have to
erase these bloody memories for and
start over
congratulations to LA - speaking of la
bringing down a Christopher Columbus
statue this last one is probably the
most disturbing to me this was an anti
fascism protest scheduled for August
10th through August 12th in Washington
DC -
pushback and to counter protests against
the unite the right rally that scheduled
in DC this is the second unite the right
rally the first one if you recall was
back in Charlottesville
a year ago when Heather hire was killed
by Nazis so these are the three
campaigns that Facebook pulled down and
Facebook didn't I give any kind of
indication in terms of their methodology
of determining what was inauthentic and
even a definition for the word
inauthentic and that's problematic
because everything that they pulled down
was left-leaning
everything that they pulled down was
something that was counteracting the
Donald Trump's administration fascism in
general the unite the right rally in
specific and so they have blanket
they've made a blanket statement on
left-leaning
operations and said that they are
inauthentic and we're not gonna hear a
single word about this and from a free
speech absolutist presence perspective
that you would hear from anybody on the
right that's the hypocrisy that we see
all of the time but we we still have to
point this out so long as the government
or so long as corporations are operating
in favor of conservatism conservatives
don't really care that is that is
violating free speech as they define it
even though it's not a true violation of
the First Amendment but I digress the
point is is that here we are with
Facebook making these judgment calls
without disclosing to the public what
what they are using or as a form of
methodology or what are they using as a
definition of inauthentic and the
organizers for the counter protest to
the unite the rally unite the right
rally to have come out and they said
that this is a legitimate rally this was
something that they plan they are
actually anti-fascist and they are
actually trying to go and protest
against fascist who are marching in
front of the White House but Facebook
has labeled them as inauthentic and have
sent messages to the 600 people who
replied saying that they were going to
participate saying that this was an
inauthentic campaign and not something
that they should attend now again let me
reiterate there has been meddling in our
election there continues to be meddling
in our political process but it exists
in many forms and and before I move to
this next point I want to pull
this first quote from Facebook because I
think it's important today we moved
removed 32 pages and accounts from
Facebook and Instagram because they were
involved in coordinated and authentic
behavior no definition there of this
kind of behavior is not allowed on
Facebook because we don't want people or
organizations creating networks or of
accounts to mislead others about who
they are or what they are doing let's go
to the next quote and this is what they
said we are still in the very early
stages of our investigation and don't
have all of the facts that's it I don't
want to read anymore I don't want to
read anymore because you don't have all
the facts and you haven't revealed your
processes to the public mind you this is
something that you should have done in
2016 but you didn't do to the benefit of
Donald Trump but now you're doing it
again now you're doing this to the
benefit of the Donald Trump let me let
me say that again because it's like a
bit of irony in 2016 Facebook did not
participate in pulling down things
inauthentic and it benefited Donald
Trump but now they're pulling down
things without telling us disclosing any
type of methodology without giving us
even the definition of inauthentic and
what they're pulling down is to the
benefit of Donald Trump this is it but I
digress here's a campaign that we know
it's fake the walkaway campaign hashtag
walkaway it is a campaign that's
coordinated by conservatives to make it
look as though people progressives and
particularly black people are leaving
the Democratic Party this campaign is so
fake and so large that it got all the
way to the steps of the Supreme Court
Clarence Thomas's wife I believe her
name is Dean Niecy Turner Niecy Thomas I
forgot her first name but she shared
images that are fake images of black
people who said that they've left the
Democratic Party this is an intentional
campaign used to self encourage self in
disenfranchisement let me say that again
this is a specific campaign coordinated
by conservatives to ensure that black
people self disenfranchise by saying oh
well I can't really be a Republican but
I'm not going to support the Democrats
anymore so I'm just going to stay home a
net win for conservatism also this camp
pain has been it has come out that this
campaign is being promoted by Twitter
accounts 600 Twitter accounts that have
connections and ties directly to Russia
we don't know if it's the Russian
government but we know these accounts
are have their origins in Russia they
have been promoting the hashtag walk
away now combine the coordinated effort
by Russians to make this campaign or to
promote this campaign and with the fact
that they are spreading fake images of
black people trying to encourage self
disenfranchisement this is exactly the
type of inauthentic campaign that
Facebook should be pushing but if you go
to Clarence Thomas's wife's Facebook
page right now you'll see these images
pull them up on your screen now I walked
away from the Democrats because when it
become when did it become incre
acceptable to encourage the
assassination of the president nobody's
encouraged that call for the physical
assault of president nobody has
encouraged that demand it before even
finished reading it this picture she
looks like such a sincere black woman
this is a stock photo this is a stock
image and it's been proven that this is
not a real person
let's go to the next one this is a meme
of the New Jersey Governor talking about
sending illegal immigrants to college
for free which is taking out of context
and underneath it you have this black
guy who looks very seriously in deep
thought and he said quote my wife and I
both work full-time and still cannot
afford to send our own kids to college
what is wrong with this picture
hashtag walk away this guy is also from
a stock photo so Facebook if you want to
really be concerned about inauthentic
and coordinated campaigns with possible
ties to Russia while you're pulling down
real campaigns of left-leaning
organizations who are fighting against
fascism you should take a look at the
wife of the Supreme Court Justice
Clarence Thomas and the walk away
campaign which is using fake images fake
stock images of black people and being
promoted by accounts with direct ties to
Russia but those images have been up for
over a week now and here Facebook is
worried about the anti fat
just rally in Washington DC next week